my energy and your energy go to the
ground Vector here I don't have his
energy I still have my energy okay so
I'm just working on my energy right your
mass has to be in that ground Vector so
that my energy of my
materiality is going down through me
onto the ground vector and just like if
he has his hands his energy now I go
ahead and I take that down he's
pushing push push push push push push
push push push push all that energy is
going down I don't need a
base energy just like I I can do it on
one leg well of course I can do it on
two without a base okay I'm not leaning
if you're not grounded when he pushes
you you will of course get push because
you need a brace angle cuz you're not
ground vectoring the energy is not
passing through you you're stopping it
here at the hand so you need that foot
okay when the energy passes through you
you don't need that foot even to project
him off again if he lets go I should not
go flying forward because my energy is
just going down he lets go and I don't
fly forward